when the first four of the seven seals
have been broken
four riders shall be summoned
conquest war
famine and death
with them these riders shall bring the
apocalypse
[Music]
you've probably heard of the four
horsemen of the apocalypse before
whether it was through the original
biblical stories or
some kind of modern reference when it
comes to the end of days
you can't go far without bumping into
the four horsemen
so who are these mysterious figures and
what exactly is their story
today's video has been made possible by
the awesome people over at wicked
clothes
if you're tired of wearing plain boring
t-shirts
wicked clothes designs clothing inspired
by folklore
mythology and all things supernatural
or paranormal you can grab t-shirts
sweatshirts hoodies or
even hats all with unique designs
tailored for those who enjoy the
stranger things in life
some of my favorite designs include the
medusa let's get stoned
t-shirt the mothman for all the cryptid
fans out there
and you can't really go wrong with a
cthulhu in space t-shirt
pretty much all the shirts are unisex so
anyone can wear them
and if you use the link
wickedclothes.com
myth you'll get 10 of your order so go
and check them out as it really helps
support the channel
the idea of the four horsemen originates
from christian
myth they appear in three main books
in the old testament the riders can be
found in the book of zechariah or the
book of ezekiel
in the new testament john of patmos
talks about them
in the book of revelation chapter 6 of
revelation
talks about a scroll in the right hand
of god
which has been sealed shut by seven
individual seals
when the lamb of god opens the first
four of these seven seals
he shall summon forth four beings that
ride on
white red black and pale
horses out of these four riders only
death
is named in the bible the rest are named
after what they represent
the lamb of god for those unfamiliar is
a title given to jesus christ
which leads us to believe if jesus is
opening these seals and unleashing the
apocalypse upon
humanity then maybe it was ordained
by god himself maybe it is a future
or punishment that humanity brought upon
itself
the first horseman to appear is the
rider in
white the horseman of conquest
then i saw when the lamb broke one of
the seven seals
and i heard one of the four living
creatures saying
as with a voice of thunder come
i looked and behold a white horse
and he who sat on it had a bow and a
crown was given to him
and he went out conquering and to
conquer
this horseman has been interpreted in
several different ways
in this context conquering meant
spreading the word of god across the
land
the reason this rider is dressed in
white would have been because
traditionally it's a color the bible
associates with
purity christ and righteousness
in the mid-19th century there were those
who claimed
this horseman represented something
closer to the antichrist
and was not to be seen as a positive
figure
the white horseman was also thought to
symbolize war
which would make sense considering war
and conquest
often go hand in hand but war is
something more commonly associated with
the red horsemen
you may also see that many refer to the
first horsemen as
pestilence instead of conquest and there
are a few reasons for this
war and conquest are fairly similar and
so in the last few hundred years
writers and scholars have instead
associated the first horseman with
infectious disease
the bringer of plague
the romans interpreted all four horsemen
slightly differently
they saw them as representing or
prophesizing
the future of the roman empire the
colour white to them was symbolic of
triumph political success and prosperity
although the white horseman may not have
been seen as christ
or religion they also saw him largely as
a positive figure
the second horseman is the rider in red
the horseman of war when he broke the
second seal
i heard the second living creature
saying
come and another a red horse
went out and to him who sat on it
it was granted to take peace from earth
and that men would slay one another
and a great sword was given to him
everything about the second horseman is
fairly straightforward
he rides on a fiery red horse with his
greatsword held upwards as a declaration
of war
an upwards facing sword would often
signify the intention to enter battle
and the color red we can assume
symbolizes the bloodshed that comes with
war
the white and red horsemen were both
connected to war
but not the same type of war conquest
implies
trying to seize control of something
through military force
in the case of the horsemen of conquest
that would mean spreading the word of
god to those who may be of a different
faith it was granted to take peace from
earth and that men would slay one
another
it's this passage that led scholars to
interpret the horsemen of war as
representing
civil war if we go back to the roman
empire
the white horseman was symbolic of the
success of rome
the red horsemen not so much the second
seal being broken
meant that peace left rome there was
bloodshed
civil war and insurrection in the empire
this is attributed to the roman emperor
commodus
whose reign is considered the end of the
golden era within rome
and the beginning of civil unrest
the third horseman is the black rider
the horseman of famine when he broke the
third seal
i heard the third living creature saying
come i looked and behold a black horse
and he who sat on it had a pair of
scales in his hand
and i heard something like a voice in
the center of the four living creatures
saying
a quart of wheat for a dinaris and three
quarts of barley for a dinaris
but do not damage the oil and wine
some believe the scales the horseman
holds can be interpreted as the scales
of
justice others believe these scales
actually reflect how bread used to be
weighed in times of famine
the mention of barley and wheat in the
above passage is why the latter
interpretation is used more commonly
the price is mentioned that may not make
much sense now
but it roughly translates to an entire
day's work
just to buy some of the ingredients
needed to make bread
so you can see how that may have caused
the famine
it also mentions the price of oil and
wine remains untouched
but these were luxuries way out of the
price range of a common worker
this can also be taken in a literal
sense
as a plague of locusts could easily
ravage crops
but grapevines and olive branches are a
bit more resolute
if the horseman is bringing this famine
as a punishment
then going after necessities such as
wheat and barley which offer little
resistance
but are of great importance does make
sense
if we once again go back to the roman
empire the third horseman
and the increasing costs of basic
necessities would represent the
excessive taxation of roman citizens
that led to the rich continuing their
lavish lifestyles
whilst everyone else struggled just to
feed their families
the fourth and final horseman is the
pale rider
many scholars describe a sickly
appearance
as opposed to a specific color like the
other horsemen
in later artistic interpretations the
color green
is what we would associate with the
horsemen of
death when the lamb broke the fourth
seal
i heard the voice of the fourth living
creature saying
come i looked and behold a pale
horse and he who sat on it had the name
death and hades was following with him
authority was given to them over a
fourth of the earth
to kill with sword and with famine
and with pestilence and by the wild
beasts of the earth
the fourth horseman is the only one to
be mentioned
by name he's also referred to as
thanatos a greek deity or spirit
associated with non-violent death
death is also described as being
followed by
hades which in this sense may not
necessarily mean the god himself
but more so hades the rest in place of
the dead
authority was given to them over a
fourth of the earth
to kill with sword and with famine
and with pestilence and by the wild
beasts of the earth
this can be interpreted as death being
given authority to kill
and hades to take the souls but the fact
it mentions by sword
famine and pestilence you would imagine
this passage refers to all four horsemen
after years of carnage famine oppression
and failures by the empire to look after
its own people
death would mark the dissolution of the
roman empire
the four horsemen have been interpreted
in many different ways
one being as a prophecy of the great
tribulation
a series of judgments from god that
caused
many on earth to die those who repented
for their
sins and accepted him as their savior
would form a new world of those who
remained
faithful the horsemen were the first of
many judgments the first seal being
broken
signifying the arrival of the antichrist
the second was global war the third
economic collapse and the last was the
death of a quarter of the world's
population
the book of zechariah takes a different
approach to the four horsemen
here they are known as four spirits who
descend from heaven on
chariots each one with a different
coloured
horse unlike in revelation their role is
not to bring the apocalypse
they were sent to patrol the earth and
maintain
peace so the account in zechariah is
pretty much the opposite to revelation
hopefully this shed some light on the
four horsemen
if you'd like to share your favorite
references of the four horsemen
then feel free to do so in the comments
section
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you